before the government deploys these
technologists further they must be
scrutinized and American public needs to
be given a chance to weigh in I was
representative Bennie Thompson during a
hearing by the House Homeland Security
Committee that he chairs on the use of
facial recognition technology by the
Department of Homeland Security that
technology is increasingly used by law
enforcement even as serious questions
remain here to discuss the topic is
Derek Thompson a writer at the Atlantic
and host of the crazy genius podcast
where he addressed artificial
intelligence and its intersection with
the justices the justice system in an
episode just last month Derek welcome to
be here before we get into that I want
to really dig deep into what it is now
not all facial recognition is created
equal
no that's true I think that it's
reasonable to think about there being
three categories of facial recognition
technology the first category is that
which at least seems to be utterly
private the facial recognition
technology that exists on advanced
iPhones you look at the iPhone it opens
up you see text from your family that is
within you could say a kind of closed
Network you in the phone you in the
phone
then there's facial recognition
technology that you clearly opt into say
the clear program for passing through
security lines I think some people that
take yeah I like it you pay for it today
there are for example also kiosks for
burger joints or other restaurants that
have facial recognition technology that
you can choose to use but then there's a
third category of facial recognition
recognition technology and that's which
that that is that which you do not
necessarily choose to enter and you
don't give explicit permission to join
so say when the city of Detroit or ice
or another law enforcement agency is
surveilling a group of people and using
their faces that they have checked
against photo IDs without those people's
permission or understanding to root out
potential criminals that is the third
category that I think privacy experts
are most concerned about and that's what
came up there was a Washington Post
report about ice officials using or
requesting that type of information from
three states why do we need to care
about this why is this important we need
to care about it because the technology
is progressing so quickly
but the law isn't and the National
understanding of that technology isn't
so as a result you have a situation
where there isn't a legal national
standard for these sort of behaviors for
ice and other law enforcement agencies
but at the same time they're already
progressing they're using the technology
against various people against
undocumented workers against people who
might be criminals walking in a crowd
and we don't have any national standard
as a result the cities and states are
having to make up their own minds and
balance to different constituencies do
we listen to the law enforcement
agencies the police who are telling us
we need these tools they're helpful or
do we listen to the public that's saying
whoa whoa whoa wait we're not ready for
you there's a balance somewhere but no
one's setting that balance right now on
the national level at least to two US
cities have banned now the use of facial
recognition technology by city agencies
does that continue I think it's actually
going to continue I think it is
extremely important in telling that one
of the two cities that banned facial
recognition technology is San Francisco
the hub the mecca of modern technology
advancement and I think what you see
there it really it really is
unbelievably ironic and I think what
you're seeing there is that isn't ironic
that the city that should understand the
implications of facial recognize ilg the
most right was the first major city the
Bennett I think that should give a lot
of cities a little bit of pause to say
what does it say that the more you
understand about this thing the more you
fear it well you know there's still some
glitches in it too the technology in and
of itself isn't perfect and and it has
civil rights implications yes it is
severe civil rights implications because
lots of different tests of facial
recognition technologies have found that
they consistently misrepresent or
misidentify non-white faces that's a
very serious problem when you consider
that ice is looking for undocumented
workers who might have come from Central
America or that the city of Detroit is
using surveillance technology against a
population that is that has an enormous
black population so I think it's really
important to understand that men only do
you need laws in the books I think you
also need third-party validators to say
this technology works
technology doesn't let's make sure that
if we are going to use this tech we
haven't using it it's being used that it
identifies people's faces equally
technology ahead of the laws Eric
Thompson thanks once again